we want to thank the fans that have
followed us it's great we won i can't
believe it i remember
wondering about
when i would have the chance to be up on
stage in the vma oh i'm falling apart
we're real happy i mean how could you
how could you not be look around
you tune in for the unexpected here this
is the front bumper of popular culture i
am introducing kings
quite the occasion
[Music]
mtv awards are my favorite everybody's
crazy wild there's no no rules britney
spears look incredible this is so
amazing because you're here with all
your peers and all the celebrities
it was the year britney spears arrived
in leather and lace then presented
michael jackson with a cardboard cake on
stage extina wore this and j lo showed
up yup radio city music hall was packed
with icons that was great get on up huh
yeah the vma is a place where no one
should feel intimidated the next big
thing comes from uh vma night i'm like
really excited
it's the coolest thing this is my first
nomination this is amazing my dreams are
coming true it's incredible
the fashion yeah it was peak 2000s
pants
helmet length tie
christian dior shirt and jacket rod
keenan
hat pony sneaks to top it all off but no
outfit is complete without wristwear the
jacob watch
if you don't got it then you don't got
nothing
but everyone did get jt's first ever
performance of like i love you i'm going
to fly in on
me so you can expect a lot of dancing
the red carpet is where the stars
collided
oh nice lincoln park lincoln park we got
to see so many of our stars that we want
to see i was standing next to usher and
i was giving an interview and i was like
and this is usher that was like right
next to me hi i just met eminem
it was kind of cool he looked me in the
eye i looked him in the eye and there's
like you know people all over us and
he's like i respect your city i shook my
hand and walked away and that that
that was awesome
speaking of slim shady himself was the
night's mvp taking home four moon person
trophies
yeah this one nabbed him video of the
year haley we got another trophy to put
in the case baby i love you
[Music]
you